we both got three shows today i'll put
you through something even better
um uh can we go back to the other one
well
you know what the other video is and we
will play we'll play i can't do this
we'll we'll play that we'll play that
one tomorrow that other video
is crowder criticizing lily sings comedy
yeah i swear to god lily made this video
and
this video now this i will say unlike
her other videos she's now getting
criticized not just by the [ __ ] us
types mike she's getting criticized by
black people going what the [ __ ] are you
doing
why are you talking like that you're
you're culturally appropriating people
what's up dog like she's doing the whole
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
check it out
how comes watch this smash anything show
them
what up make it happen with your belly
full up no matter your size
now is this i don't know look i've never
i've never really
been yes i've never been to toronto
is this is this a typical toronto accent
this is how they talk
there in toronto
forget all that okay i [ __ ] care
about appropriation i really don't okay
remember the white guy that did the
uh the reggae music and dumb and dumber
like these
this thing's been around what about snow
and formulas no there's plenty of these
guys i don't care about that
but i thought she was a late night show
host comedian
what's the point of this the point of it
is is i don't think the late night show
is going to
last okay but she just is she gonna be
reggae artists now that's what i don't
get like what's the point
uh what is the point of this royce well
her rap video was great before remember
the m
m one when she did candies and some by
the way the m m one somebody pointed it
out
she was ripping off mcp pants from aqua
teen hunger force
i like taffy bubblegum that's what she's
exactly what she was ripping off
um
oh this is a body positive song for
those of you who can't understand what
she's saying
sorry it's okay i'm trying please you
could be mad
and also you're doing like uh body
positivity hey we're all beautiful
and then you're like [ __ ] wearing
like a [ __ ] a tube top
and showing off your body that's not
terrible so
like it's in that kind of you know what
i mean like isn't that kind of
counterproductive it's like it's like
that [ __ ] rejoining you make you get
these [ __ ] models that show their
[ __ ]
flat washboard absolutely you're the one
faster oh body positivity y'all and it's
like all right you're not making the fat
girls with stretch marks feel
any better right now
and look i agree with you i don't you
know i don't give a [ __ ] about
cultural appropriation but she's
supposed to care about it
she's the woke one that's the stuff
where i that's what i'm calling out is
like
i don't give a [ __ ] like i don't [ __ ]
care i think one of the funniest
characters on tv is jay rock you brought
it up earlier i think it's [ __ ]
hilarious
i think it's great i don't give a [ __ ]
but she's supposed to care
you're the woke one you're the woman of
color do you know that
this is a woman of color yeah i guess
apparently yeah she brings it up i'm
just pointing out this because a lot of
people are asking would you
uh i don't think my dick could get hard
for lily sing at this point because i
would i would you know too much
i know too much would i [ __ ] an exact
clone of her
that's not her and doesn't think they're
talented
of course yeah without a doubt like you
know i mean like
a chick that looked like this but just
like worked at a bank
and by the way it's not racist i know a
lot of indians work at banks it's not
i'm not trying to be racist it's meant
any normal you know whatever 7-eleven
um but like that yeah there's a chick
that just looked like this and was like
you know a a waitress at ruth's chris
i'd be like yeah
you know what's up but not lily sings
specifically because
she'd be like oh check out the sketch
i'm working i'd be like ah you're not
good at this like now
i can't [ __ ] you
[Music]
[Music]
listing things and saying the same thing
over and over again this is bad
this is bad even for lily
[Music]
i don't i don't get it but
girl power is just awful can i can i
sense yesterday but can i show you
something
yes it's just some kid who makes youtube
videos with his dad he'll say 184
subscribers and whatever but
he likes on this to me so thank you dg
um
it's not just us guys check this out
do you think a politician can answer
that a politician's more likely than me
to get that
i don't know about that
maybe or what your answer is or what the
truth on that is what's up with the mass
by the way
he's a kid you're a [ __ ] weird kid
you know what i mean kids are weird
he's pretty smart though check this out
um
okay but okay so if we can't necessarily
or can't figure out a way to
fix it all what are some things you can
do that will help out the world though
son
um i don't know
maybe maybe get rid of willie sings
late night show get rid of who
lily sings late night show
why because it's generic
and boring let's get rules
let's get a rules and by the way
[Laughter]
imagine this kid is like the
the perfect demographic for being easily
amused right yep like like remember when
back in the day uh when we were that age
like
providing us with entertainment was a
slam dunk it was easy right
[ __ ] a little bit of gargoyles some
wwe
like it was very simple this
there you go it was very simple to just
like go watch attitude error wrestling
everybody i guess like oh my god it was
so genius it really wasn't
but it was simple they kept the formula
simple right
bad guy does the thing somebody flashes
their titties bad guy comes out
bad guy tries to block you from seeing
the titties stone cold comes out stunner
everyone goes home feeling like their 50
they spent was worth it it's
kids boys this age
should be so easily immune it should be
easy and even he knows it's generic and
boring and stupid
and she's untalented that's not good
somebody says how's this different than
mini aoc i'll tell you how it's
different
this isn't some sort of political
activist or dragging out the shows
this is the te this is the target
audience for lilly singh
yeah and also yeah they're not really
it's just a dad and his kid [ __ ]
around on camera
yeah he's not going hey hey kiddo i need
you to go own the lib targets yeah no
yeah go on the lib targets what about
lily call all the girls that ever had
abortions murderers on this video we're
gonna put that up it's gonna be so based
yeah like it's like
and then i'm gonna get attention finally
because i never made it at
anything in life so hey kid come here
come here
i failed at everything i need you to do
me a favor tell me abortions murder say
it was by the way it was funny because
you could tell even the dad when he said
lily's thing that dad's like
who has even the dad he would know but
but these are the this is the h demo
that's on youtube
okay okay what else
um i don't know she just preaches that
she's a
woman of color and then expects
everybody to laugh
i like this kid he's all right
is he a fan i don't know it's supposed
to be comedy